is that no hope for you yeah it is hot
it is hot but i think i'm distracted by
what's going on whoa
[Music]
hey what's going on and happy holidays
hot ones fans this is shawn evans coming
at you from the cozy hot ones cabin
which may or may not be located in the
middle of an office block in midtown
manhattan and we're gathered for the
first ever hot ones holiday extravaganza
a spicy december treat and it's all for
a good cause as we hopefully help our
charity partner common threads reach
their fundraising goals so they can
continue to provide nutrition and
cooking classes for families in need all
across the country there's some more
information a donate button just to the
side of this video waiting to be smashed
what is the hot ones holiday
extravaganza well you know what i'm
happy that you asked we'll have our
first ever taste test of hot ones junior
the only sauce that to our knowledge has
been made specifically for kids we have
festive dishes made by your first we
feast favorites nicole russell alvin
kylon george moats as well as the
inaugural hot ones awards hosted by poor
man's ricky gervais camera guy bill
and i know that you clocked it in the
cold open you saw the thumbnail and it
had a pavlovian pull for anyone whose
blood runs spicy and that is the
long-awaited return of gordon ramsay and
let me tell you something if you thought
the sequel couldn't top the original
santa has got a whole new bag of tricks
so all i can say is stay tuned and all i
ask in return as a humble chicken wing
talk show host is that if you're able
please consider a donation to common
threads whether it's a dollar five
dollars five hundred dollars every
little bit counts to help kids in
under-resourced communities make
affordable nutritious and appealing food
choices wherever they live work learn
and play please consider if you're able
it would mean the world to me and to the
families who are supported by common
threads and now let's kick this thing
off the only way we know how with the
kids who helped inspire this event in
the first place it is the super official
hot ones junior taste test with the
young spice lords of common
to hot threads junior
kaya take one mark hi my name is kaya
i'm 12 and i'm from brooklyn my name is
owen i'm 12 years old and i'm from
brooklyn my name is liv i am 12 years
old and i'm from brooklyn new york my
name is ethan i'm 12 years old and i'm
from brooklyn you told me you took a
couple of virtual classes with common
threads can you tell me what you learned
in those classes like different diets
and how to get the protein and starch
and all that good stuff basically the
nutrition facts of cheerios and
different things like that and about
different things that we can make at
home making like healthy snacks so you
can eat after school and we also learned
about the serving size that you need
have you ever had hot sauce before i
have i have had hot sauce before and do
you like it no usually when i have fries
i put ketchup and hot sauce on my fries
i'm not super into hot sauce so not
really i've had spicy food but i don't
eat it regularly at least not as
regularly as my brother what if i told
you that we
created a hot sauce just for kids
that's cool i actually don't believe
that though
oh
it's green why is it green
[Applause]
it's really cool
how do i hear a sauce
it kind of looks like gogurt uh you know
there's like two tubes of gogurt where
it has the uh the ant the not the
animals the green
hot sauce by heating
i have no clue how to pronounce this
word sadly i've never heard of it in my
life
hot ones junior it says junior i like
that i like that so there's apple in it
no sugar added green apple apple juice
sweet onion lime juice baby spinach
apple cider vinegar jalapeno peppers
banana kosher salt extra virgin olive
oil and fresh basil it actually sounds
pretty good you know something's good
when you can like recognize all the
ingredients there was like literally
only one spicy ingredient so i like that
i don't really like onions that much and
apple cider vinegar but yeah
[Music]
it smells kind of sweet and spicy
actually i do smell a lot of green
apples it's almost like i can smell each
ingredient almost so you ready to taste
it yeah all right let's bring it in
[Music]
thank you in case it's too spicy
let's bite into it
[Music]
hmm
that's really good
i think i'm a bit ready to try some more
on a lot more
excuse me
it's a tiny bit sweet but mostly spicy
and it's pretty good my tongue is
stinging a little bit
i can feel the spice but it's like it's
really nice so you can't really taste as
much of the spice which is pretty good
for those who may not like as much spice
and what about the apple cider vinegar
i actually didn't taste it i forgot that
was in the ingredients list honestly you
get a little dash of spice and then you
get a little bit of
childhood memories it tastes really
really good which i like in a like
excuse me it tastes pretty good it
tastes like a hot sauce but it's still
healthy for you
it's good you'll be missing out if you
don't
thanks for watching
thanks for supporting common threads
happy holidays everyone back to you sean
wow
which one of those kids do you think has
taken my job in 10 years because my
money is on ethan and if you'd like to
put your money on ethan as well consider
taking a stroll over that donate button
and contributing to common threads and
of course if you want to get your hands
on hot ones junior you know the drill
heatness.com heatness.com to order and
you know the goal of common threads it's
not only to just provide meals it's also
to provide cooking instructions that
those kids can take that education back
to their families back to their
communities and make those choices those
healthy lifestyle choices in the long
term so with that in mind we challenged
the host of the burger show pizza wars
and burger scholar sessions to make us a
festive dish that's fit for the holidays
alvin take it away
thanks sean and happy holidays to
everybody who's watching first we feast
fans i love you y'all are the best sean
i know there's nothing more iconic than
the chicago hot dog so guess what i'm
turning it into a burger today buddy
is it a hot dog
is it a burger
who cares it's the holidays
all right y'all let's get started check
this out i'm subbing out the hot dog i'm
taking the hot dog out i'm taking the
glizzy out
and we're subbing it with a burger
shaped like a hot dog
so we ground this beet fresh today it's
chuck brisket rib eye a bunch of steak
trim we'll season this with salts and
just throw it on just like you would a
hot dog
boom this is kind of like um like kebab
beef you know so it makes sense i'm not
the only one who's doing this this makes
sense that looks fire
poppy seed bun staple for a chicago dog
and you're just gonna drape it over the
burger like this just so that it can get
nice and warm i'm gonna pull this off
just like that
let's chicago dog this up
so what i noticed in chicago is there's
always a whole pickle spear and it's
always faced
like that i'm going to transfer this to
my hot dog tray we're going to add a
little bit of heat and a little bit more
acid with chardonnay then we're gonna
add relish
for the sweetness let's top it with a
couple of these chilies and last but not
least you can't forget a couple shakes
of celery salt
chicago style burger dog for you buddy
mistletoe
i'll be your taste buds
there's nothing wrong with that
that is delicious that is fantastic
[Music]
what the hell is this
oh you guys
you shouldn't have oh i love gifts man
what
bro
burger phone
i've always wanted one of these y'all
are the best
the best team in the world
happy holidays
i love you
thank you
oh
i gotta take this call nicole take it
away
happy holidays everybody i'm nicole
russell from pizza awards and today i'm
going to teach you how to make spinach
oni skincione is also known as sicilian
christmas pizza or sicilian new year's
pizza for this i wanted a highly
hydrated dough because i want it to be
light airy and crispy this is what your
dough should look like stretched out to
the corner a little bubbly what i'm
going to do with this conchoni dough is
i'm going to par bake it so it can
support the toppings okay so my dough is
part baked so i got my own secret recipe
sauce here no you can't know what's in
it
for sevenchony you can go all the way to
the edge with your sauce we're gonna add
some anchovies and this is gonna pack a
lot of flavor you wanna put a liberal
amount of bread crumbs so it soaks up
all the sauce and that's what really
makes a good skin tone so we're using
traditional cachiavallo cheese this is
like a harder cheese than the average
mozzarella and it has a little bit more
sharpness to it so right now we're all
set this is traditional right you can
leave it right here but why i'm gonna
put some onions on top of here these are
some caramelized onions and now i'm
gonna add a little green because it's
christmas so let's go we're going to add
a little bit of green olives to this we
went all around the edges we're being
really generous with our toppings so
nothing left to do but to throw it in
the oven and bake this for about 10
minutes
you can see what happened in the oven
the bread crumbs got nice and toasty
it's gonna be good
are you dreaming of a white christmas
i am
so we got a little crispy booty on the
bottom that's what we want all the sauce
and the breadcrumbs go to the edge so
good i want to take a bite is that all
right with you okay let's go
oh my god
you're gonna love this
do this asap
super easy to make at home not
complicated at all don't stress yourself
out it's christmas
and yes please don't forget to hit that
donation button happy holidays from the
first week beasts family to yours
look how
oh what's cute like surprised i am
surprised
oh my god what's this
oh i wonder what it is
oh my goodness
i love it
pizza earrings
thank you so much i'm putting them on
i love them for real though thank you oh
is it mine it's a frog oh no no
i gotta ask because i still got a trophy
thank you so much that was so much fun
now let's see what george is cooking up
in his kitchen
thanks nicole welcome to the burger
scholar headquarters holiday edition
as you can tell i'm the kind of guy who
goes all out for the holidays i love the
holidays the party is here
i get to dress up
i get to pull out my fake white tree and
light it up i get to drink eggnog but i
also get to make you
a burger and not just any burger
the tortilla burger from new mexico
we're going full christmas on you that's
right christmas it's locals only term
for when you want red and green together
on the same plate christmas
see what i did there
okay
let's do this one of the elements is a
very large flour tortilla
i'm gonna heat it up a little bit just
get a little hot
between two pieces of parchment paper
this should be yeah no that's not that's
not smart hang on
[Music]
burger's down
the burrito the burrito we've got warm
refried beans we also have warming on
here red and green chili from new mexico
they have two very different flavors one
is
very bright and the other one's very
smoky and deep you put these two
together you have
absolute like new mexican cuisine magic
flipping okay
refried beans smear that in cheddar
cheese on top of the refried beans the
patty goes on top of that let me wrap it
up but we're not done yet on top of this
goes red and green chili happy holidays
on top of that the cheddar cheese again
more cheddar on top and then this goes
into the broiler here you go you got it
[Music]
ah
the new mexican tortilla burger with oh
my god
smells so good
oh knife and fork
[Applause]
life and fork
[Music]
that's good
oh wow that's good
if you live in new mexico
green chili and red chili pretty much
goes on everything
why not on a burger
happy holidays
[Music]
from the first we feast family and for
the holidays we got you a little gift
okay
is it gonna explode in my face is it hot
oh
it's
a cactus the [ __ ] is this thing jesus
is it alive
is an animals thank you for my new
aloe plant
it's for all the burns oh
got it it's for all the burns
oh yeah oh look at that
oh for the burns oh
yeah thank you for this perfect holiday
gift
back to you sean
wow a hot dog hamburger it's so
beautiful it could make a grown man cry
and now it's time to really turn on the
waterworks as we present the first ever
hot ones awards looking back on the
history of the show who's going to take
home the lifetime achievement who had
the biggest meltdown who had the best
wing 10 will any of our illustrious
guests add an h to their egot i guess
only time will tell and there's no one
better to help shepherd us through this
momentous ceremony other than my guy
camera guy bill camera guy bill take it
away
[Applause]
it's the hot ones awards
it's the spiciest the mightiest the hot
ones awards
they'll be
celebrities golden amenities the hot
ones awards
thank you for that wonderful
introduction sean welcome one and all to
the first ever hot ones awards show this
is a celebration of your favorite
moments and memories of hot ones past
and present the hot ones academy has
been hard at work re-watching 16 seasons
worth of celebrities taking on the
10-win gauntlet and picking award-worthy
moments and let me tell you something
the academy takes this very seriously
we've curated a list of categories and
nominees that really brought the heat
and it's about time they get some
recognition in the form of a custom-made
golden hot sauce bottle
look at her what a beauty so without
further ado let's get to our first award
we've had some of the most talented
musicians in the world at our table and
every now and again the wings of death
give us an impromptu show of a lifetime
these are the nominees for the best
musical moment
russell brands owed to superfan brett
baker
t-pain singing into a toy t-pain
microphone
john mayer playing the ukulele
and the winner is
t-pain
congratulations mr t-pain
[Music]
what's good guys your homeboy t-pain uh
first and foremost want to say thank you
to hot ones everybody over there sean
evans uh the spice kings everybody that
that made this happen because you guys
have had a ton of great guests uh
especially musical ones so
i'm glad i got the musical moment
because i'm just better than everybody
so
that's how it works suck it everybody
else um
i'm putting this right next to the
grammys thank you guys again and uh yeah
let's do it again just spicier i got a
burp coming but i don't know where it is
i feel it okay here at hot ones we have
been known to ask celebrities to do one
final task before we send them home some
tasks harder than the others in some
tasks we don't even ask them to do here
are the nominees for best wing ten
moment babish getting a hot one's tattoo
logic finishing a rubik's cube stevo
chucking a bottle of hot sauce and then
putting it in his eye and the winner is
stevo
[Music]
hi i'm stevo and when i first found out
i was gonna be on hot ones i was so
stoked man i thought dude i'm a star and
now
to be presented with this hot ones
best wing ten moment award whatever that
means
it's just an honor beyond belief thank
you
a shooting star you are stevo and adios
mio is that a hard wing tend to watch
get it i idios mio ah you know yeah okay
let's go speaking of doing something
crazy we've watched our sauces take down
their fair share of celebrities over the
years some a bit more gracefully than
others here are the nominees for biggest
meltdown tyra banks switch with the
cameraman eric andre laying down on his
couch eddie juan eating wing 10 first
and the winner is
miguel tyra banks
[Applause]
i can't believe that i've won the most
entertaining reaction award this is
amazing i want to thank everybody
especially cameraman
bill
you
just couldn't have done this without you
and
i wish i could say i'm crying but really
i can't stop eating hot wings
and i can't stop
soothing it with
ice cream
but now it's my ice cream
from camera guy bill to cameraman bill
thanks tyra i certainly wouldn't be here
if it wasn't for that meltdown
congratulations
now while some guests might not be able
to handle their spice we've also seen
our fair share of guests come in and
handle the wings like a true champion
not even breaking a sweat here are the
nominees for wayne warrior charlize
their own
lord
halle berry
and the winner is charlize their own
come on down hi
hi guys oh my god thank you it's so
heavy it's like
it's like it's heavier than the oscar
this is amazing this is actually better
than the oscar because my kids are not
impressed by my oscar and i think this
will really impress them i mean look at
that that is so awesome
yeah [ __ ] apparently i can deal
with some spies so there you go um
sean i love being on your show
every time i come on it's my favorite
part of the day
and uh
i hope we get to do it soon again
and um i'm really touched by this you
guys honestly it's been a while since
i've won anything so
sending you guys a hot kiss make out
session it's coming over here it comes
well charlize saying that award means
more than your oscar is one of the
greatest achievements of my life
speaking of achievements i think it's
about time we introduce our first ever
hot ones lifetime achievement award this
award goes to the person or persons who
have given us so much quality content
over the years from their episodes at
the table to their episodes in their
homes and who could forget truth or dab
these two guys have a special place in
our channel and in our hearts i give you
tom segura and bert kreischer
sean spice lords everybody at hot ones
bert and i are thrilled to receive our
uh lifetime achievement award uh it's
like my favorite show ever to exist on
the internet sean you're the greatest
and we both are big fans of hot sauce
yeah i think on our weight loss journey
our hot sauce has meant so much to both
of us so thank you so much for awarding
this to us
i'm through the roof is our hot
sauce well i don't even know what to say
to that one all i know is next year i'm
hosting this without my shirt thanks
bert well there you have it spice lords
the first ever hot ones awards thank you
to all our winners and nominees for
giving these great moments i cannot wait
for more celebrity reactions and
memories to come you're all winners in
my heart oh wait wait i'm being told
that i missed one award the the most
creative antidote award well i think you
all know who won that i mean he came
with a mary poppins bag full of goodies
i'm told he brought even more this time
well i guess i shouldn't keep you
waiting any longer ladies and gentlemen
back for round two versus the wings of
death our grand finale to the holiday
extravaganza
it's gourd on ramsey
hey what's going on everybody at long
last we've reached the finale of the hot
ones holiday extravaganza and let me
tell you something
we are doing it big to close things out
a man who needs no introduction on this
channel whatsoever
the 100 million view man
chef gordon ramsay
welcome back to the hot ones experience
um first of all
my [ __ ] ring still on fire
everywhere i go
it's not about masterchef or hell's
kitchen it says we love the [ __ ] hot
ones how hot were they
that's amazing yeah um good to be back
merry christmas
they told me there would be some
surprises today
i'm done eating [ __ ] food okay if we're
gonna do this thing again
we need to have
a proper [ __ ] wing last time i
told you i'm not eating that dry [ __ ]
from grandad's toenails to [ __ ] bits
of unwanted quail
they
are [ __ ]
in here is a wing
i'm talking about a three-mission style
wing a wing with elegance and when you
open the box you're going to be
surprised because first of all
whoa chicken lollipops
if you're going to celebrate the return
to this incredible competition yet again
trust me i want to eat some [ __ ]
chicken
[Music]
well i guess this means though that
we're dressing them ourselves yes
so you just what are you are you
covering yeah got a little cupboard whoa
okay
everyone said last time especially my
son jack said dad there wasn't that much
sauce on there was there i said dude let
me tell you there was enough sauce on
there i swear to god my ring's still
bleeding
um right how nice is that to hold a wing
with some elegance lovely is that three
michelin star lollipop right there you
go
right
hmm
so before we get too deep into the
interview i want to do a quick
post-mortem on the fateful day that was
almost three years ago where you walked
in with a mary poppins bag of spicy food
antidotes and left us with one of the
biggest interviews in the history of the
internet what's the fan feedback been
like for you on the street ever since
that aired there's probably not a day
that goes by where someone doesn't ask
me about it i think the most exciting
for me was just how young those demos go
in terms of 12 year olds saying hey will
you will you go back on there again and
i'm like no what's the [ __ ] one you
go no sorry no i won't um everywhere i
go honestly from the ass end of
honduras
to a jungle in guyana
um and i'm about to rappel out of a
helicopter 250 foot down and the pilot
okay is trying to talk to me about the
third question on hot ones i'm like dude
i'm hanging out with this [ __ ]
helicopter from my ball back you're
about to unleash me you know onto a
sector of this river and there's
alligators down there i'll discuss the
hot ones in a [ __ ] minute
he was more interested in the [ __ ]
hot ones than getting me safe on the
ground that's how popular this
competition's become how many f-bombs if
you had to guess do you think you
dropped during that interview and then
we'll put the real number next to your
guess here um
well you were winding the [ __ ] out of me
you winding me up so you were sort of
you were being very popular it was my
fault and
[ __ ] first time round
35 35 might be underselling it just a
little bit but we'll compare that to the
real number are you ready to move on
here to the next sauce no i need to show
you what's inside my shirt sure
literally
so
just
oh
he's got more antidotes
i am so [ __ ] organized you've got no
idea
now
that
cools everything right down
and just in time and now all that heat
is disappearing okay
i feel like i've just kissed the [ __ ]
sahara desert because my mouth is stuck
together but
that is way smoother now so i've lined
my palette
so next time around with that sauce it
won't be so pungent i promise
[Music]
that's a big jump from the first one
last time around we did a 10-wing
gauntlet here it's a five-wing gauntlet
which is nice fewer wings but the ramp
up
much more vertical
back into the sack
it's christmas so
i'm gonna do a beautiful little just
like wow
a sort of
a cocktail right
this is amazing
and also it's festive
now this is gonna cool that thing down
okay
do all your guests come on with gifts
like this no uh you know you've really
uh you've really set a trend here and
also
you need to come
prepared right
yes you brought the lemon and the lime
back of course i did
here we go
now
look at that
that is
a beautiful
cocktail
cheers cheers merry [ __ ] christmas
merry christmas
[Music]
that's very nice do you like that don't
you i do like a citrusy sort of pina
colada situation that's exactly that and
the cooling element the coolant are your
eyes getting a bit watery or just
getting tearful because it's christmas
oh listen i've got a lot of i got a lot
of mileage on me gordon you know ever
since you sat here i've probably shot
another 150 episodes since i saw you
last i'm wearing down um
i
i get asked by chefs all over the world
um
is he that good it's sean evans i said
he's a real [ __ ] deal let me tell you
these rings are [ __ ] but the questions
are great
so last time you were on the show we hit
you with some viral food creations
including sushi donuts which you
remarked must have come out of portland
so given the success of that segment
what i want to do is bounce a few
general food topics off of you just to
get from chef gordon ramsay are they
overrated are they underrated and why
in and out
delicious i mean really delicious animal
style yeah really smart hand-cut chips
you know the drive-through is
extraordinary except i have to crawl
through the [ __ ] window every time to
do selfies with them and turn around and
then they say it's on me so no no i need
to pay for it no no it's on me now i'm
going to pay for this thing so in and
out worth it 100 yeah beautiful nando's
uh nando's uh tilly our youngest
daughter is obsessed with nandos
truthfully between you and i the kids
have been i've never been to a [ __ ]
nando's wow ever
what about truffle oil truffle or yeah
uh
pungent
overrated and chefs use it like
vinegarette it needs to be put in a
pipette it needs to be dropped into a
vinaigrette and then mixed throughout
and so
when you've got amazing albuter truffles
perego truffles okay
enhance that season don't spoil it any
chef that sticks truffle law on top of
truffles is a fake bastard because let
the truffles aspire to be what they
should be
oh excuse me second wing in that shit's
already regurgitated a 12 bottle here's
the issue everyone's obsessed with
summer truffles the worst truffle on the
planet they look like a truffle they
taste like [ __ ]
truffles should be eaten for six seven
weeks a year and then we say goodbye to
it so to go from the beautiful white
truffles in the winter pogo travels
through february march and then to go to
summer truffles we're missing the
[ __ ] point
summer truffles taste like a mouth of
[ __ ] sawdust wow coupled with a touch
of that first set of wings you gave me a
few years back the ones that look like
my granddad's toenails
stay away from summer truffles they
taste of nothing
so that is very very
fragrant whoa
smells delicious ah
yeah
oh my god
oh my lips
santa's got
he's got a massive sack i'm for having
flashbacks
oh what is this
is that no hope for you yeah it is hot
it is hot but i think i'm distracted by
what's going on
[ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is in that thing and i'm
back and i'm back
i swear to god
holy [ __ ] it's still burning is that
only number three only number three only
number three
we got a couple more to go i don't know
what you have left in that sec but this
next one's crazy
[ __ ] i know i know what is that that is
it's just the straight buddle of fire
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] boots with some kick
with some kick
cakes
of all the cooking demonstrations that
you've done on your youtube channel or
on talk shows is there a celebrity guest
that's really impressed you with their
skills in the kitchen
first of all it's not [ __ ] sean evans
have you made that scrambled egg yet you
know what it's forever changed the way
that i make scrambled eggs i love with
that creme fresh you changed my life
with that
[ __ ]
sorry [ __ ] it now
okay
[ __ ]
[ __ ] me that is not normal that that
that should come with a health warning
on the side well wait till you have the
next one
um
we had a uh um an extraordinary moment
uh at rolos road where
bradley cooper was filming burnt
and so we had a couple of dinners
together and he just wanted to get into
the mind of that chef because it was
going from a two star to a three star
what what did it take and
sadly we've had chefs that have
committed suicide based on being told
they were going to lose a certain point
so i say to young chefs you lose
anything in life dust yourself down win
it back it's only a star and it's like
the champions league you're going to be
in that mix next year so don't take your
life because of a [ __ ] guide don't be
so stupid
and so
halfway through
the second dinner we had together in
fact um he came over to the house for
dinner um
and
all of a sudden i started seeing him
plate food i was in christ he's only
been in production for six weeks he's
working so hard at this and now he's
sounding like a chef and some actors act
it and some actors do it and act it out
brilliantly he actually got into the
headspace
of a chef and understood what a mind
[ __ ] they are yeah and how competitive
they are and that was a a a beautiful
shock for me to witness someone working
that hard across a movie and boy i mean
it showed because he came across
brilliantly
[ __ ] noises running again why'd you
do this to me
[ __ ] because it's so much fun every time
you're here gordon
this next one is the bomb beyond
insanity you might remember it from when
you were on the show
okay so the bottle looks super dangerous
yeah how hot is this on a scale of one
to ten what where 12 oh [ __ ]
this one oh okay small dabs on this one
small dabs that is very beautiful is
this one of yours again no no this one
is not mine this one is not mine i i do
not claim it
i do not condone it i do not endorse it
look how look how dark it is
yeah so that's uh that's rich isn't it
that is very rich
jeez
be very careful be very careful
[ __ ] me now
[Music]
that's just [ __ ] my wing yeah because
that has obliterated my wing do you mean
i might as well be eating one of [ __ ]
bobby flays [ __ ] appetizers
that is [ __ ] disgusting
i kid you not obliterated
did you like that
no no no
just for this part of the show but no
thankfully we got so bread
a little bit of milk soak it
[Music]
quick
and the bread will absorb all those
[ __ ] spices
okay
wash that palette there we go i think
i'm back i think i'm back
on the way over
it's gonna sound super strong i wasn't
gonna get [ __ ] taken down and [ __ ]
fourth bottle in that thing is uh man
that's powerful that yeah and it's
called the bomb yeah you actually had it
last time you were on the show
that one really yeah and does that come
with like a sort of bowl of toilet paper
it should because you should absolutely
[ __ ] yourself on the way home with that
thing
almighty you should they should have you
curate
a little uh first aid kit that goes
along with the sauce beyond insanity on
the bottle it is way beyond it how much
is that
uh this one probably that's probably a
eight to ten bucks situation right there
so
on this wing what we want to do is
introduce a food element don't worry
we're not going to be making scrambled
eggs again but
i want to lean on your british roots to
get a little crash course in puddings
i'll just bounce a pudding off you you
tell me what it is and the best time to
eat it yeah spotted dick
spotty dick is a traditional sponge that
is steamed with um
tiny raisins and it's an old-fashioned
english dessert that
comes out in this sort of well it's like
a dick shaped sponge and you slice it
and you're supposed to serve a little
bit of butter traditionally sticky
toffee pudding
sticky toffee pudding is one of my
favorites that's for the puree of dates
and you make this incredible uh
sponge and then you soak it in this
toffee and it's delicious especially
with something like a salted caramel ice
cream i can taste [ __ ] all now by the
way yeah i know generally it takes me
three or four days i know you think i'm
[ __ ] around i brush my teeth every
[ __ ] hour when i finish this show and
then i swirl that [ __ ] listener mint
you know that just uplift raise and it
still numbs it so
no not good
listen welcome welcome to my world
that's how i feel 24 7. and then i
understand that with a christmas pudding
it's kind of tradition for uh for people
to hide coins in it or or different
little prizes so we've given you a
christmas pudding and you have a little
spoon we have a little present in there
for you you're not the only one bringing
gifts today it's very kind thank you
thank you
are you [ __ ] serious the boss
yeah that's our [ __ ] order come on
man jesus
christ all right gordon ramsay
[Music]
i didn't know whether to sneeze fart or
piss myself
i've got stuff caught the top of my nose
now how do i get that back down
we're just forever changed jesus
baptized by hot sauce
this is the last dab we call it the last
dab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
just two seconds
i bought your [ __ ] present
i brought you a present now [ __ ]
yourself i'm going to take you back now
set up pots and pans
[ __ ] it i'm taking them home to my mum
whoa i am
serious i am not [ __ ] around for this
last one
i have got my [ __ ] together
fuego blaster
right source
where were we the last dab
okay light dab little light dab little
light dab
oh excuse me
[ __ ]
i never burp or belts like that
[ __ ] yeah it brings it out of
you this show
my stomach's all
hot
my armpits are [ __ ] sweating
i know you know i always i was so
excited to see you today and and and you
to see me and then i feel like you
probably don't want to see me for a
while after christmas
okay
[Music]
[ __ ]
no
no no
no i just can't eat that
my very variant line of pepto-bismol
no it is pepto no
[ __ ] how
gordon ramsay at long last you have the
distinction now of completing the hot
ones gauntlet yet again and i just want
to say on behalf of myself and first we
feast
i want to thank you your episode it's
one of our proudest accomplishments and
you've done more for this silly little
chicken wing show then you'll ever know
so what i want to do is present you with
an award a real reward here it is from
dom for the most creative hot sauce
antidotes and i should point out that
today you have topped yourself again the
floor is yours for the accepted speech
go and [ __ ] yourself
2.0
[Applause]
[Music]
the gordon ramsay experience
we are very lucky to have him a second
time
please if you appreciate the sacrifice
hit that donate button happy holidays
hot ones fans
wow
quarterback it's gonna be so [ __ ]
good it's gonna be so [ __ ] good
good to see you good to see you thank
you everybody uh take care of yourself
there is a beautiful set of pot and pans
for you really thank you so much
handcrafted homemade i love that thank
you
thank you
[ __ ] good good to see you man
well there you have it the hot ones
holiday extravaganza is in the books if
you enjoyed the show
please if you're able consider a
donation to common threads it means the
world to us here at first we feast
and happy holidays hot ones fans this is
now seven that we've spent together i
love when we reconnect here at the end
of the year and you know what we'll do
it again next year as well hot ones
we'll see you again in 2022
happy holidays
[Music]
foreign
you